[Music]
have you ever heard of Medusa the
snake-haired Greek monster who turns
people to Stone with a single glance
well she may just be a myth but there is
an area so deadly that it could actually
turn you to Stone
the infamous Lake Natron
what makes Lake natron's water so
dangerous
what kind of creatures live there
and could you survive if you fell in
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you jumped into Lake Natron
before we take the plunge we'd better
look at what lake Natron is made of
much like the Dead Sea this Tanzanian
Lake doesn't run off into any oceans or
Rivers
this allows it to soak up all that salty
Desert Rain
[Music]
soupy yet what makes it especially
lethal is its close proximity to the
active volcano lengai
the volcano spews a rare kind of lava
rich in sodium and potassium carbonate
called nitrocarbonate or matron for
short
releasing into the water this mix of
sodium carbonate and sodium bicarbonate
were key ingredients once used in
Egyptian mummification creating the
perfect preservative in Lake form
the whole chemical composition is
extremely alkaline with pH levels of
10.5 close to that of ammonia
this gives the lake its Rosy hue
any birds who happen to take a dive and
don't make it out become calcified in a
hardened stone-like husk
[Music]
talk about killing two birds with one
stone
in 2013 wildlife photographer Nick
Brandt was one of the first to document
this phenomenon he discovered several
Stone birds and other unlucky animals in
the dry season when the water had
receded
he theorized that since the lake is so
mirror-like and reflective the birds
must have flown right into it as if it
was a big glass door
but despite so many birds dying in Lake
Natron there is a particular species
flourishing turns out the Lake's toxic
Waters provide a safe haven from
predators making it perfect Flamingo
flocking grounds
so if flamingos can handle it couldn't
we
well it's not that simple unfortunately
flamingos thrive in salty Lakes because
of their tough skin and scaly legs which
prevent Burns
they can drink the fresh water from
nearby Springs or geysers at the edges
of the lake and if they're desperate
enough they can even filter salt water
with special glands in their nasal
cavities
and to top it all off their strong
stomachs allow them to feed on the toxic
algae found throughout the lake
this makes Lake Natron the perfect spot
to raise and protect their young
so let's say we've tried to live like a
flamingo and decided to take a dip
well depending on the time of year the
water can be up to 60 degrees which is
hot enough to cause third degree burns
in five seconds or less
also I wouldn't plan on doing any fancy
Dives or cannonballs as its shallowness
is also chock full of sharp salty
structures
you wouldn't be turned to stone
instantly but if you happen to drown and
stay submerged your entire body would
Harden and be preserved
if people found you hundreds of years
later you might still have your hair and
organs intact
yeah still looking spiffy after all
those years
like mummification natron's super high
alkalinity stops the decomposition
process
thankfully this means you'd be safe from
vultures or any other hungry scavengers
looking for a snack
if you waited into the lake at a time
when the water temperature was lower it
could feel more like a hot tub
but your eyes or any open wounds would
sting like crazy because of all that
salt
I'd strap on some goggles if I were you
in 2007 another bird flew straight into
this chemical cocktail a group of
wildlife videographers plunged into Lake
natron's toxicity when their helicopter
crashed
the pilot suffered a broken leg and
another passenger had a broken hip
incredibly one of the passengers managed
to struggle to Shore and alerted some of
the Maasai tribes people nearby
they quickly built stretchers and
carried the injured to land in the nick
of time
even though you could survive lake
natron's waters I'd stick to a swimming
pool if I were you
you know videos about falling into
things very popular on what if you may
have seen what if you fell into the
world's deepest hole what if you fell
into a pool full of piranhas what if you
fell into a pit of snakes of course
there was Lake Natron uh we've got some
more deadly Lakes coming up for you
later on in this Marathon but first what
I want to say to you is
you may recall that's the name of the
volcano in Tanzania that feeds the
natural carbonate into Lake Natron so
it's goggles and wetsuits if you want to
go swimming in Lake Natron but what if
you went to Antarctica well it'd be
parkas and Boots obviously but have you
ever thought about what's underneath
Antarctica it's not just ice floating in
the middle of the ocean there is land
underneath there and it's not always
hospitable
deep beneath the thick layer of million
year old ice
something is lurking quietly waiting to
rip through the rigid ice sheets
not that this enormous icy Wasteland is
sitting on top of a volcanic Ridge
and in our hypothetical World these
volcanoes are about to wake up
could their scorching lava Wipe Out the
surface of Earth
or would the thick Antarctic Ice stop
the lava before it makes our planet
uninhabitable
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Antarctica's dormant volcanoes
woke up
Antarctica is the coldest continent on
Earth
and it's quite mysterious
we didn't know it had active volcanoes
buried underneath it until 2013 when
scientists accidentally detected two
clusters of small earthquakes
now that we've scanned Antarctica with
ice penetrating radar we know that there
are many more volcanoes hiding below the
ice
138 to be precise
but that's only the ones we know of how
many more could be hibernating there and
how much trouble would we be in if all
those volcanoes suddenly decided their
Slumber was over
it shouldn't be too surprising that
these Ash breathing ruptures have been
buried underneath Antarctica's ice
Shield this whole time
after all volcanoes are easy to come by
even outside our home planet
there are volcanoes on Jupiter's moon IO
Saturn's moon Enceladus
and on our planetary neighbor Venus
but let's not waste our time there
we've got our own world to save
do you know what happens
volcano erupts
there are usually warning signs before
the real action begins like the waves of
earthquakes
they indicate that there's molten rock
moving beneath the surface
then lava and Ash join the party
accompanied by heated gases
it depends on a variety of scenarios and
the kind of lava involved but on average
lava moves at about 10 kilometers per
hour pretty easy to outrun but when a
major eruption occurs a volcano releases
superheated gases and Ash combined they
create something called a pyroclastic
Cloud these things are hot reaching up
to 700 degrees and they can move at 80
kilometers per hour
being trapped by one of these would mean
the end of days for you
but Antarctica's volcanoes are a
different story
they're buried under layers of ice that
are more than four kilometers thick in
places we wouldn't be dealing with
volcanic gases making their way to the
surface
at least as far as one eruption goes
the heat released would melt massive
caverns in the ice creating substantial
amounts of melt water and that's when
things would start getting ugly
the newly created melt water would cause
the ice above it to move more rapidly
the Antarctic ice cover would begin
heading into the ocean
from there the domino effect would kick
in
the huge weight of the ice puts all that
pressure on volcanoes keeping them
stable but decrease that pressure and a
volcano gets limbered up and magma finds
a way out through an eruption
in the case of Antarctica multiple
volcanic eruptions could wake up over a
hundred other volcanoes and destabilize
the entire region
as the volcanoes continued to blow their
tops more melt water would be created
causing more of the Antarctic Ice to
slide into the ocean
Antarctic Ice would be enclosed by
warmer ocean currents
on one hand we'd get a new look at
Antarctic Bedrock that's been hiding
under the ice this whole time
on the other hand the ice wouldn't just
disappear into thin air it would melt
and if all of Antarctica's ice melted
it would raise the global sea level by
about 60 meters
rising sea levels could contribute to
Major storms moving slower and dropping
more rain
hurricanes and typhoons would wreak
havoc on the Earth's surface
Wildlife along coastal areas would lose
their habitats and agricultural soil
would become contaminated with salt
extensive flooding would push millions
of people away from the coastline
if the eruptions happened in the span of
one day
we'd be looking at thousands of deaths
and storms wiping out everything
floating in the oceans
but let's go back to Antarctica for a
second
now that all the ice has melted what
about the rampaging magma
the good news is it wouldn't turn the
earth into a lava world after all the
eruptions would occur underwater
the hot magma would solidify in the cold
water of the Antarctic ocean and maybe
add more real estate to Antarctica's own
bedrock
but things don't end there
when volcanoes erupt on land they spew
out heated gases including carbon
monoxide methane carbon dioxide and
nitrogen
to go along with this there's usually
some water vapor thrown into the mix
by some estimates volcanoes are
responsible for the release of 645
million tons of carbon dioxide every
year
if the Antarctic volcano eruptions
turned out to be powerful enough
they would blow open huge expanses of
ice allowing the release of even more
toxic greenhouse gases
when one of Antarctica's surface
volcanoes Mount takai erupted some 18
000 years ago
it spewed out the chemicals that ate a
hole in the ozone layer that hole warmed
up the Southern Hemisphere and caused
glaciers to melt it helped wrap up the
last ice age
[Music]
if you traveled to the deepest points of
Earth
what would you find
Lost Cities mythical sea monsters
rivers of gold
probably not but there's still a lot to
discover so join me as we travel deep
underneath the surface to explore some
of the most inhospitable places on Earth
what lives at the bottom of the Mariana
Trench
how much of the ocean is unmapped
and what is mind deep below the Earth's
surface
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you explored the deepest
points on Earth
not many people can claim that they've
been to the deepest points on Earth but
Victor vescovo can
from 2018 to 2019 viscovo LED an
expedition that visited the deepest
points in all five oceans
the five deeps Expedition covered 87 000
kilometers in just 10 months and
completed 39 Dives using a small
submarine
for your trip you're only going to visit
one trench the Mariana Trench
you'll need to save about three quarters
of a million dollars for the trip but
you'd be one of the few people to
explore this deep
what would you see as you descend
first you'd need to travel to Japan from
there you'd take a submarine about 2 000
kilometers out into the Pacific Ocean
Challenger Deep the deepest point of the
Mariana Trench is almost 11 kilometers
below the surface and it would take
about two and a half hours to reach it
there will be a lot to look at in the
beginning of your descent the first 200
meters below the surface is where most
ocean life thrives
as you travel deeper it becomes darker
and the less Wildlife you'd see
though you'd still get to witness the
occasional whale diving for food
you'd see your first deep sea creature
the fangtooth at one kilometer below the
surface
this appropriately named fish is 16
centimeters long with 2 2.02 giant teeth
to make room for them the fang tooth has
two sockets beside its brain
as you travel deeper than 2500 meters
there are no more whales they don't
usually dive down this deep
but when you hit 8 000 meters you'd
encounter the Mariana snailfish at this
point the atmospheric pressure is nearly
1100 times what you feel at sea level if
you weren't inside a pressurized
submarine it would be like having the
weight of a fully loaded truck on your
head
those little snailfish out there must be
pretty strong to withstand all this
intense pressure
eventually you'd reach the very bottom
the Challenger Deep if you look closely
you might spot an amphipod species
hyundalea gigas these small deep ocean
creatures are only about three
centimeters long
and that's about it down in the Mariana
Trench no secret treasures hidden cities
or sea monsters
next it's time for you to travel to the
world's deepest sea volcano the West
Mata volcano
this underwater site is located
Southwest of the samoas you'll need to
rent another submarine to travel down
1200 meters below the surface
but since you just visited the Mariana
Trench it should be no problem for you
if you're lucky the volcano would be
active and you would enjoy seeing lava
fountains and glowing bubbles
just be careful of all the debris that
erupts into the ocean
both the West Mata volcano and the
Mariana Trench are natural deep points
on Earth
but what about something that's man-made
[Music]
Goldmine is the deepest operating mind
in the world around 4 000 miners work in
it every day
and despite safety precautions it's
still risky
in March 2020 a seismic event killed
three miners who were three and a half
kilometers below the surface
to get to the mine you'd need to travel
to the gauteng province in South Africa
you'd take the elevator known as a cage
with 119 other workers until it reaches
two and a half kilometers below the
Earth's surface
as the elevator doors open you'll notice
the Heat it's about 30 degrees and
that's only because the mining company
has created a system to cool down the
air
without fans blowing over a mixture of
ice and salt the mine would be a
whopping 60 degrees
why
because you're so deep in the earth that
its inner heat is warming up the
surrounding atmosphere
you'd only be two and a half kilometers
underneath the Earth's surface
to go lower you'd need to walk or drive
the rest of the way
you'd be at the bottom of the mine when
you reached four kilometers
that's as deep as 10 empire state
buildings
luckily there are no cave creatures to
worry about down here the only life down
here other than the miners is monotypic
bacteria
while the opening gold mine is
impressive all of the deepest points on
Earth are in oceans
according to NASA over 80 percent of the
oceans remain unmapped unobserved and
unexplored and if we want to continue to
explore these areas we're going to need
to take better care of our planet
they're not the biggest falls in the
world
not by a long shot
but they're certainly among the most
famous Niagara Falls attracts millions
of visitors from around the world every
year
people come for the history
they come for the romance they come for
the spectacular View
but some people just can't get close
enough
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into Niagara Falls
there are three different waterfalls
that make up Niagara Falls but the one
that gets all the attention is the
Canadian Horseshoe Falls
the Canadian Horseshoe Falls is about 57
meters tall and 670 meters wide
water rushes over its Edge at a peak
speed of 109 kilometers per hour
dumping about 2.8 million liters of
water over its Edge every second
considering its height its speed and its
raw natural power
it's hard to believe that anyone could
survive a trip over the falls
and yet it's been done
several times
was it skill or was it luck
how do you survive a fall into Niagara
Falls
the first person to survive a trip over
Niagara Falls was Annie Edson Taylor in
1921 on her 63rd birthday she crawled
into an oak and iron barrel and floated
right over the edge of the falls
Taylor performed the stunt for money and
fame but she didn't earn much for her
feet
nonetheless Daredevils seeking to follow
in her footsteps were not deterred in
1928 for example Jean lucier went over
Niagara Falls in a 182 centimeter Rubber
and steel ball lined with 32 inner tubes
Lucia survived the fall and spent the
rest of his life selling souvenirs to
tourists
not all the Daredevils were as lucky as
Taylor and lucier
of the 16 people who've tried to beat
the Falls just a little more than half
have lived to tell the tale
to date only five people have survived
an unprotected fall down the Canadian
Horseshoe Falls
the first and youngest was Roger
Woodward in 1960. he was only seven
years old at the time when a boating
accident caused him to be swept
overboard and over the edge of the falls
Woodward was rescued shortly after and
made a full recovery after spending just
three days in the hospital being treated
for a concussion today that event is
still referred to as the Miracle at
Niagara
most Rescuers and experts at Niagara
consider unprotected survival stories to
be blind luck but there are some
strategies that might just save your
life if for any reason you find yourself
hurtling 109 kilometers per hour in
freezing cold water towards the edge of
a 57 meter drop
the first thing you need to remember
just before you go over is to take a
really deep breath
when you reach the bottom there will be
so much water swirling around you not to
mention the intense pressure of the
water falling from above that you can
easily suffocate
so taking a big gulp of air before your
fall could buy you some time
you'll also want to take precautions to
protect your head if you can Orient
yourself so that you fall feet first
then you'll want to wrap your arms
around your head with your elbows over
your nose and clench your eyes and mouth
shut as tightly as possible in fact you
should tense up all your muscles and
bring your legs together before impact
making your body as watertight as
possible
you're already incredibly lucky if you
survived the fall but that doesn't mean
your ordeal is over
the water temperature below the Falls is
around the freezing mark
which gives you about 15 minutes to get
out of there before hypothermia kicks in
you'll likely be badly bruised and
terribly disoriented but if you can stay
calm and focused
you might just be one of the lucky few
to survive a fall into Niagara Falls
of course the best way to survive is to
pay attention to the warning signs and
respect the safety rails after all the
Falls are huge do you really need to
risk your life to get a closer look
[Music]
all that stands between you and a fool
of boiling rotten egg smelling acidic
water is humble Boardwalk
and your good judgment
stray off the path and you could be
headed toward quite the swim
heads up scorching temperatures would be
just the start of your problems
how long could you survive your
accidental dip
how would it feel to swallow these
colorful Waters
and why might there not be anything left
of you to save
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a yellow stone
Hot Spring
Yellowstone National Park is one of the
most iconic in the United States and
it's situated atop a volcanic hot spot
if you decided to take an off trail hike
you could accidentally walk right into
Emerald spring
this hot spring is located in the Norris
geyser Basin and it looks spectacular
except you'd notice that the visuals
don't make up for the stench
yeah you'd catch a whiff of what smells
like rotten eggs
that's the result of sulfur eating
microorganisms that create sulfuric acid
the acid evaporates and turns into
hydrogen sulfide gas which gives off a
putrid Aroma oh
get a little closer and you'll be able
to feel that the green waters are hot
sizzling hot
there's no way you'd even want to stick
a toe in them
but
it might not be up to you
as you approached the dazzling but
stinky hot spring the ground around it
would seem solid
and then you hear a crack
ground at your feet gave way to your
body weight you were standing on a
delicate crust formed by underground
minerals dissolved by the water and then
redeposited on the surface of the spring
all of this made the crust as thin and
fragile as a sheet of ice
your whole body would be completely
submerged you'd Now understand why the
word hot in Hot Springs is not an
understatement
the Blazing temperatures hitting 82
degrees Celsius in places would send a
sharp pain through your skin that's
dangerously close to Waters boiling
point
before context temperatures of 50
degrees Celsius can give you third
degree burns in five minutes
if you fell into Emerald spring chances
are you'd be dead in three minutes or
less
now before things get really nasty you
could try to push through the pain and
pull yourself out of this mess
but even then the outcome wouldn't be
pretty
you would end up in a hospital in
critical condition clinging to your life
but if you didn't make it out in time
you'd begin to boil from the inside out
and this would be just the agonizing
start of your very unavoidable demise
you see hydrothermal vents help turn
Emerald spring into a potent Acid Bath
by perpetually infusing it with chemical
microbes on top of that microorganisms
compound the problem by breaking off
pieces of the surrounding Rock and
adding sulfuric acid to the pool all
that makes falling into Emerald spring
the near equivalent of dousing yourself
with hydrochloric acid
when Emerald Springs water touched your
skin it would cause your tissue to swell
and bubble if it wasn't for your
gurgling you'd be able to feel the
popping of your exploding blood vessels
you'd start to bleed out
the fat under your skin would also begin
to bubble and with all that screaming
you'd swallow more and more liquid acid
that would burn through your stomach and
destroy your internal organs
if your lifeless body wasn't pulled out
in time all that would remain of you
would be a thick coat of blood fat and
tissue floating on the top of the
emerald green water
after a 23 year old man fell into a hot
spring in the Norris geyser Basin
authorities had to delay retrieving his
body due to a thunderstorm
the next day nothing of the unfortunate
visitors body remained
urban legend has it that all the
authorities found were his wallet and
flip-flops
sadly he's just one of 22 people known
to have died from hot spring related
injuries in and around Yellowstone since
1890.
in a best case scenario you would end up
in critical care battling third degree
burns
worst case you're dissolved into a fizzy
goo
so follow the park rules and don't
wander off the designated paths
hey hot enough for you
yeah I hate when people ask me that too
it's open now but in actual fact it has
been hot enough for me people in regions
all over the world including mine have
been suffering through some pretty
intense heat waves lately I'm not gonna
lie it's been pretty uncomfortable not
to mention pretty stinky if you know
what I mean but what if you lived in the
hottest place on Earth all the time year
round 40 degrees celsius 100 plus
Fahrenheit Heats every day
well there are people who do it have a
look
ever wonder what it would feel like to
step into an oven
Welcome To Death Valley California
temperatures here can climb to a
scorching 54 degrees Celsius
which is as cozy as the internal
temperature of a steak in Death Valley
it's so hot you could fry an egg without
a stove
but how soon would you get fried
yourself
what would your days in the hottest
place on the planet be like
what could you do to survive this
intense Heat
and what could happen to your body if
you weren't careful
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you lived in the hottest place
on Earth
it's so hot you can barely breathe
this National Park that stretches across
California and Nevada might as well be
hell on Earth
located 86 meters below sea level it's
the lowest point in North America and
the surrounding mountains trap the
superheated air like an oven
for five months of the year temperatures
hover around 48 degrees
you'd think that life there would be
unsustainable but it turns out that
Death Valley isn't always dead
it comes to life in the spring as
colorful wildflowers Bloom and the
temporary Lakes fill the lowlands
and besides the tourists visiting the
park around 500 people live there all
the time
so pack your bags you're moving to the
scorching hot desert to join them
life in Death Valley would be very
different from anything you may be used
to not just because of the heat but
because it's quite a commute to well
anywhere
the nearest high school and shopping
center is an hour away it's a two-hour
drive to the closest major city and
there are no doctors dentists or
restaurants around
despite this or because of this there's
a tight community in Death Valley
in the Cow Creek complex residents of
its 80 units share a gym a playground
and a library and since they don't get
many visitors during the hottest times
of the year they end up spending a lot
of time together
though there isn't much of an
entertainment scene in Death Valley
there's a lot to see Outdoors
I mean after all we're talking about a
national park
you could listen to the tiny pops and
pings of billions of salt crystals
bursting apart in the heat
maybe enjoy the view of the colored
Hills thanks to the oxidation of natural
metal deposits in the mountains
you could swim in a water-filled cavern
and if you're lucky you could even catch
a devil's whole pupfish a rare fish that
can withstand the hot water
life in Death Valley doesn't sound so
bad
except for that
it would take some adjusting to the Heat
when our body temperature reaches 41.7
degrees it can become life-threatening
this is known as hyperthermia and it can
lead to deterioration of internal organs
and eventually death in the climate
extremes of your new home you could
easily heat up to the point of
hyperthermia
your best bet would be to take it slow
first don't forget the sunglasses as the
salt covered Basin can be blinding under
the sunlight make sure you always have
sunscreen and protective clothing and
avoid staying outside in the warmer
hours usually from 4 to 5 30 pm
if you don't want to die of hyperthermia
you should prepare before you even set
foot in the desert
your ability to survive in a hot climate
is largely determined by your body shape
and size
that's because heat is a byproduct of
cell metabolism
so larger animals with larger bodies and
more cells typically produce more heat
dropping a few kilos or pounds might be
a good idea to adjust faster
most people adapt to the heat after a
few weeks but it could take you a full
year to get fully adjusted
at this point you'd have a lower core
temperature and your blood vessels would
increase blood flow to your skin
you'd also start sweating more not that
this should be a problem and once you
start wearing a sweater at 27 degrees
you'd know you're officially acclimated
feel like upping the stakes of your late
night skinny dips well welcome to Lake
NEOS one of the most dangerous lakes on
the planet
here your Cannonball might just take
thousands of lives
what makes Lake NEOS so deadly
how much damage could it cause
and how bad a splash will you make by
Falling in it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into Lake Neos
in the northwest region of Cameroon
Africa over a volcanic crater lies Lake
Neos
a small lake with depths of about 210
meters
Crater Lakes like NEOS tend to release
carbon dioxide due to volcanic activity
deep below
usually this carbon dioxide dissipates
slowly as the lake naturally shifts
but if the lake stays still enough the
gas dissolves into the water and
continues accumulating there so steadily
turning it into a ticking time bomb
so what would happen if that water were
suddenly Disturbed
NEOS is one of Only Three Lakes known to
accumulate deadly levels of carbon
dioxide
agitating this kind of Lake could cause
something called a limnic eruption but
hold on let's not get too far ahead of
ourselves
have a front row seat to this
catastrophe
and without even knowing it you'd be the
trigger of a major disaster
as your body sank into the deadly Waters
of Lake NEOS the dissolved carbon
dioxide would rise to the surface
the lake would start to bubble and these
bubbles would cause even more turbulence
have you seen the famous Diet Coke and
Mentos eruption
yeah that would be you
a 90 meter water jet would explode into
the sky sending you flying as high as
Big Ben in London
we'll say you're lucky enough to survive
the drop but you'd still have all the
carbon dioxide to deal with
in 20 seconds all of the accumulated gas
would be Unleashed in a cloud over one
kilometer wide
it would spread as far as 25 kilometers
away from the lake and it would travel
at a speed of up to 48 kilometers per
hour
silently choking most of the living
creatures in its path
if you were in a village nearby instead
of soaking in Lake Neos you'd hear a
strange rumbling sound followed by the
sight of a white Mist rising from the
lake the deadly gas cloud would then
Usher in a gust of wind putting out any
fire that might be around you
this is because carbon dioxide gas is
heavier than air and at high
concentrations it displaces oxygen no
oxygen means no combustion and no fire
but it also means you wouldn't be able
to breathe you would drop dead after a
single gasp of air
this is exactly what happened in 1986
when a landslide or an earthquake
triggered a limnic eruption on Lake Neos
in total
1746 villagers and 3 500 livestock died
instantly
no one was there to witness how it's
usually Serene Blue Waters turned red
from all the iron churned up from the
bottom
still up for a swim at the most
dangerous lake on Earth
well the lake NEOS disaster happened
when the concentration of carbon dioxide
in the lake was at its highest
and since 1986 some safety measures have
been taken to avoid this happening again
like a pipe at the bottom of the lake
that now allows the gas to escape safely
still I wouldn't recommend risking your
life for this experiment
even with some of the gas being vented
NEOS has just way too much carbon
dioxide
this is the deepest hole mankind has
ever dug it's a straight drop into the
bowels of the Earth
for 20 years Russian scientists and
Engineers drilled deeper and deeper
hoping to uncover whatever Mysteries the
hole May hold
earning it the ominous nickname of the
well to hell
what would happen if for whatever reason
you fell into this hole
what would happen to your body
how deep would you fall
what would you find at the bottom
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into the deepest hole
on Earth
so you managed to take the plunge you'll
start plummeting at about 10 meters per
second and every second after that it
gets faster if we take terminal velocity
out of the mix and assume you weigh 80
kilograms you'd eventually reach a speed
of 490 meters per second
so as you fall deeper and deeper what
would happen to your body
falling at such high speed you'll start
to notice things getting a little toasty
as your heart rate starts to elevate and
panic sets in you might find it getting
a little harder to breathe
why well at 150 meters down your poor
lungs would be getting crushed by the
constantly increasing air pressure
you might also encounter what cave
explorers like to call foul air deadly
underground pockets of carbon dioxide
great things can't get much worse can
they
yeah they can
they can less than three kilometers into
the trip you're going to see your skin
start to burn up literally
and as you continue to fall it only gets
hotter and hotter
this is because you're being pulled
closer to the gravitational Center of
earth and its molten core which is
baking the planet from the inside out
a temperature of 80 degrees can severely
burn a person's skin in less than a
second
at this point in the hole you're feeling
heat of over 180 degrees
on the bright side you've probably
already passed out
when you fall out of a plane you can
pass out from lack of air but wake up as
oxygen becomes more available and catch
a glimpse of the ground as you smack
into it
down here you're not waking up
okay so things don't look good but let's
say you came prepared and wore an
atmospheric diving suit to help with the
increasing pressure as you felt it's
heavy but it will help with that
breathing problem
in 2016 Luke Aikens jumped from over 7
600 meters without a parachute and
survived without a scratch
granted he'd landed in a net
so if he's allowed to have one you can
too
okay so you land in the net great
including your terminal velocity you
have successfully managed to free fall
12 kilometers straight down at a speed
of 200 kilometers per hour how long were
you falling
well factoring in air resistance and
terminal velocity the whole trip took
just over three minutes
and now you've got to get back out
this is not going to be easy but it may
not be impossible in 2018 Alex Honnold
managed to scale Yosemite National
Park's 914 meter tall El Capitan Granite
wall without ropes in just four hours
granted he wasn't wearing a huge suit
like you are this big outfit wouldn't
help you climb and you would need some
climbing equipment to help you get a
better grip on the walls of the hole
but what's it like down there to answer
that let's flash back to 1971 in the
cola peninsula of Northwest Russia to be
exact when Russia began work on the cola
super deep borehole measuring in at just
over 12 kilometers deep the cola super
deep borehole is the deepest hole
humankind has managed to dig on Earth
team Cola had managed to break the world
record for drilling depth trying to get
a leg up on the U.S during the Cold War
eventually though they encountered
temperatures of 180 degrees which melted
their equipment so the hole was capped
in 1992. when you're at the bottom you'd
find things are warm to say the least
not to mention your body would be
dealing with air pressure equal to 54
elephants perched on top of your head
weighing in at a whopping 378 tons
talk about a headache at least you could
admire some of the 2.7 billion year old
rocks down there
but really could something like this
falling down this hole ever happen
who knows to be honest we're still
trying to figure out the equipment
requirements for digging this deep let
alone finding someone crazy enough to
take the plunge
luckily the cola super deep borehole
only has a diameter of 23 centimeters so
it's too narrow for you to trip into
and even with its record-breaking depth
the cola super deep borehole is only a
fraction of the thickness of the Earth's
crust
but it does make you think about what
humans are capable of went to a party
last night and I got stuck talking to a
super borehole but that's another story
The Cola super borehole has been sealed
up so you can no longer fall into it or
drop things into it but you'll get two
more chances to fall into Super borehole
soon because China is digging two more
one is going to be ten thousand five
hundred meters deep the other one's
going to be 11 000 meters deep let's
just hope that they also keep them to 23
centimeters so that my waist does not
fit through there okay our next story is
kind of timely because a week or so ago
a former Air Force intelligence officer
was testifying before Congress about
UFOs and he believes they exist that the
government knows about them and that
they're not telling you about it now
we've heard about UFOs before they've
been debated in Congress but this is the
first time a witness has ever been
brought forth now he didn't have any
physical evidence so we don't know what
to believe but if you want to try and
find some physical evidence
why don't we all get together in storm
area 51.
if you happen to wander into the Nevada
desert and stumbled upon the secret U.S
military base area 51.
you'd quickly be arrested killed or
maybe even abducted by aliens
but what if you happen to organize one
million other people through social
media to storm area 51. I mean they
can't stop us all right
or can they
and if you did manage to get into the
base what would you see
this is what if and here's what would
happen if one million people stormed
Area 51
if you haven't heard of it before Area
51 is a highly classified U.S military
base
it's heavily rumored to have secret
military technology
and perhaps aliens
for decades it's been the source of
conspiracy theories but now you want to
see if any of those theories are true
[Music]
how do you get to Area 51
it's off limits to visitors so it may
not be on your GPS
but there are online guides that you'll
need to use
the closest airport is in Las Vegas
from there you'll have to rent a car and
drive through the southern Nevada desert
for several hours
keep in mind that there are going to be
one million other people doing the same
thing as you
if you think traffic in your city is bad
just wait till you see this
Nevada's most populated city Las Vegas
has less than 800 000 people living in
it in fact the entire state of Nevada
only has about 3 million people
adding another million people all at
once would seriously damage Nevada's
infrastructure
the roads to get to Area 51 aren't an
eight-lane Highway instead they're small
two-lane roads and dirt trails
if one million people decided to do this
they may not even make it to the
military base
instead they may get stuck in traffic or
get into an accident so much for seeing
any aliens
but let's imagine that everyone somehow
makes it to the front Gates of the base
now one million people are ready to
storm area 51.
what happens next
well you and your friends are peaceful
people so you wouldn't be carrying any
guns
you're just simply running into the base
as soon as you crossed the area 51
borders you'd quickly be met by the
base's private security these people
also known as camo dudes have weapons in
hand and Patrol the base 24 7 in white
pickup trucks
you wouldn't be able to sneak up on any
of these guys as they surely know you're
coming
and it wouldn't just be the private
security trying to stop you with an
event this big the whole world would
surely know and it would be impossible
to keep it a secret Area 51 is a
Detachment of Edwards Air Force Base
which is located in Southern California
thousands of active military members are
stationed at Edwards
you could expect to see them along with
thousands of other armed soldiers and
police members they'd have their guns
tasers tanks and who knows what else
the armed forces would try to keep
casualties at a minimum but they'd still
be hitting everyone with pepper spray
and other non-lethal weapons they'd
still be determined to keep what's
inside Area 51 a secret
so most likely the camo dudes and their
military counterparts would open fire on
the crowds and they're authorized to use
deadly force so don't be surprised if
they started firing bullets if you're
lucky enough not to get shot or pepper
sprayed you'd get arrested
but what if you somehow managed to sneak
past
the guards
well despite this you still wouldn't be
at the actual Area 51 base at least not
yet you'd have to find it
that's because the original Area 51 base
occupies a space of 150 square
kilometers but the property surrounding
it is 1600 square kilometers
it's reported that the base is discrete
with blacked out windows and hardly any
visible lights from the outside
you could be walking around for hours
before you found it but once you've
reached Area 51 what would you see well
we're not really sure what's there which
is what makes this so exciting crazy
military technology UFOs or even aliens
could be lurking about proceed with
caution though as some suspect that the
base is heavily polluted from Decades of
government experiments
if that's true just being in the base
without proper equipment could result in
you getting sick or dying
so storming Area 51 probably isn't a
good idea it would most likely result
with you getting sick or arrested or
dying
sorry you won't be getting a baby alien
as a souvenir gift
whoa watch your step
one little stumble and you could fall
face first into a pit full of nightmares
hundreds of angry rattlesnakes
how would they be able to see you
what would happen to your body if you
were bitten by hundreds of snakes
and why would sucking the venom out not
save your life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a pit full of
snakes
rattlesnakes live in the forests
grasslands and deserts of the United
States and South America
who can identify them by their
triangular head shape and of course
their distinctive rattle running into
even just one of these serpents in the
wild would be enough to make you scream
and there's a good chance you'd find a
lot more than one
rattlesnakes often live together in dens
or snake pits to avoid freezing and
protect each other from predators
if you fell into one of these deadly
pits rattling with venomous vipers could
you make it out alive
pick the wrong day to fall into a
hibernaculum that's the official Latin
name for the dens where snakes gather
together depending on the snake pit and
your luck
could find yourself face to face with
anywhere between 8 to 300 rattlesnakes
winter is the most likely time you'd
find hundreds of them congregating for
warmth if you happen to fall directly on
top of these snakes it would be only a
matter of seconds before they'd attack
yet by some stroke of Good Fortune you'd
land in the den without immediately
disturbing them
that's not to say that you'd be out of
trouble because these snakes would be on
high alert
their primary defense mechanism is to
hide and you just blocked the only exit
rattling and hissing to scare you off
they'd use a couple of unique methods to
hurt you
the rattlesnakes would know exactly
where you are
during the day these snakes can detect
You by sampling the air with their
tongue and tasting it with an organ near
the roof of their mouth known as the
Jacobson's organ
this organ tells a snake which direction
higher concentrations of Airborne
molecules are coming from
at night rattlesnakes use their pit to
locate you yeah no I don't mean the hole
you just fell into I'm talking about a
small Hollow spot between a
rattlesnake's eyes and nostrils it's
also called the pit
this area of the snake's head contains a
membrane that can detect infrared
radiation from your warm body
just like in the Predator movies
all of these hundreds of snakes would be
able to see you up to one meter away
now the only question would be how soon
till they strike
oops I spoke too soon the first one
would sink its fangs into you injecting
its venom under your skin
even if only one of the hundreds of
snakes bites you you'd be in trouble
approximately one out of every 736
people who suffer from a rattlesnake
bite dies
that means more people die from
rattlesnake bites than any other snake
bite
as more and more snakes began to attack
you they deliver more of their poisonous
venom to your body
it only takes seconds for the venomous
cocktail to travel from the fangs and
into your tissues
but what is this deadly concoction
rattlesnake venom is a complex mixture
of different proteins metals and
macromolecules that affect your organ
systems
the venom coursing through your veins
contains enzymes that lead to cell death
known as necrosis
at first you'd experience some of the
less severe symptoms mild swelling pain
and bruising but you could also start to
vomit or see your heart rate rise to
more than 100 beats per minute if more
severe symptoms kicked in you'd feel
extreme pain like being stabbed or
burned by an explosion
your Airways would start to swell
cutting off your Air Supply and you
could slip into an altered mental state
but the worst would be yet to come
your blood would become unable to clot
so you'd lose a ton of it and your
muscles would become weak stiff and
would even start to break down entirely
this would make escaping the pit very
difficult
you'd have to find all the strength you
could muster to climb out of this snake
pit and now you'd need to get some
anti-venom as fast as possible ideally
within four hours
anti-venom stops Venom from binding to
your tissues which is what causes
serious blood tissue and nervous system
problems
the question would be how much would you
need after being bitten by so many
snakes
one young girl in California who
survived bites from one adult and six
baby rattlesnakes required four doses of
Anti-Venom
you might need more than the hospital
has in its inventory
and beware trying to suck out the Venom
from your wounds or making a tourniquet
wouldn't help you much in this case
cutting off the blood flow would just
lead to a higher Venom concentration in
one side of your body
the best thing to do would be to stay
calm don't touch your wounds and of
course get medical attention immediately
oh you just fell into a pool with this
thing
what is this
how would falling in here affect your
health
and could you actually survive this
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a pool full of
spent nuclear fuel rods
this is a spent nuclear fuel pool
and you've just accidentally fallen into
it
but what exactly is this thing
this large pool of water is meant to
cool spent fuel rods after they come out
of a nuclear reactor while powering a
nuclear reactor these fuel rods become
very very hot we're talking 2 800
Degrees
after it's spent three to six years
inside of a nuclear reactor a fuel Rod
is no longer efficient problem is it
still emits plenty of harmful radiation
and it will for the next 10 000 years
even though it's trash there's not a
garbage dump in the world that will
accept it so why is water a good place
to put these things
not only does the water spend several
decades cooling the fuel rods but it
also affects their radiation
the water essentially acts as a
biological shield with hydrogen
absorbing and deflecting the radiation
bouncing against it
this makes it completely safe for you to
stand near the pool with no ill effects
but what happens if you fall in the
water
well as soon as you Orient yourself
you'll quickly notice the temperature of
the pool
this big tub of water won't be the
refreshing dip you're looking for on a
hot summer day instead it'll be around
30 degrees
so a bit colder than your average hot
tub but still very warm let's hope you
didn't accidentally turn off the water
flow as you're falling into the pool if
you did then you'd be in some serious
trouble
spent nuclear fuel pools are constantly
cycling out water in order to keep it at
a cool enough temperature
remember these fuel rods are incredibly
hot and if the water isn't cycled out
then it would heat up significantly and
slowly evaporate over time
resulting in you burning to a crisp
but that didn't happen so now that
you're starting to swim in this hot pool
of water when does the horrible
radiation poisoning kick in
or when do you turn green and start to
gain superpowers these are the sort of
things that are supposed to happen when
you fall into something that has nuclear
fuel in it right not exactly although
that sounds like fun it wouldn't happen
to you if you fell into a spent nuclear
fuel pool
that's because of the water not only
does it protect the people outside of
the pool it'll also protect you if you
happen to fall inside one
as long as you don't swim several meters
underwater to touch the fuel rods you'd
be completely fine
yeah in theory you could swim in this
pool until you looked like a raisin
without feeling any negative effects
although they're protecting something
incredibly dangerous spent nuclear fuel
pools are quite Serene and kind of
boring
in fact this might be a lot cleaner and
safer than your average public pool
you won't find any germs or children
peeing in the water here
and swimming in this pool would expose
you to less radiation than you
experience in your everyday life
we encounter radiation in medical
procedures such as X-rays and CT scans
from certain fuels like gas or coal even
our televisions and other screens give
off tiny traces of radiation
swimming in here isn't any more
dangerous than watching a what-if video
if splashing around in a spent nuclear
fuel pool is a little too boring for you
how about swimming on one of Saturn's
moons
well that sounds like a story for
another what if
[Music]
hey thanks for joining us on this
Marathon today we really appreciate the
fact that you stuck it out right till
the very end now we're going to try and
bring you one of these every week so if
you want to be notified of when they're
going to happen or maybe you just want
to see when the next single what if
video drops well hit like And subscribe
and you'll get a notification as to when
they're going to happen in the meantime
if you're not done with us well we've
got about a thousand other videos on
this site so take a look around I'll